He didn't kill your brother I did
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is
going to be my mandalorian season 2 episode
3 video there was so many easter eggs and so many
big things that they set up so we have to break
it down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes we're
doing a new disney plus memberships giveaway all
you have to do to enter is leave your favorite
moment from the episode of your favorite easter
egg on the video really big spoiler warning for
everything that happened during the episode and
everything that's happened on the mandalorian so
far because there is a lot that we have to talk
about we'll do top 10 wtf and easter eggs as we
go along starting with number 10 the title of
the episode is the heiress is a reference to
Bo Katan Kryze's character because she's kind
of like the heir to the throne of mandalore
but like the other mandalorians after the purge
she's been living in exile trying to rebuild
their forces so obviously that's a big part of the
episodes is setting up that plot but it's just the
very beginning of that there's so much more story
there that they have to explore it was another
really really short episode but i think it's a
great example of how the actual length of episodes
doesn't really matter as long as the episodes
themselves are amazing and this is probably one
of the best episodes that they've ever done one
of the big complaints with last week's episode
is that it wasn't really canonical there wasn't
a lot of mythology that they got into or they
didn't really push the narrative forward so much
of episode three with katie sackov's character
was doing that pushing the narrative forward in a
really big way broadening the story universe so to
speak it was directed by bryce dallas howard who
directed season one episode four i think she did
a way better job with this episode so i'd expect
her to come back and direct a season three episode
and maybe on whatever spin-off series they wind
up giving to katie sakhoff's boca tan character
i'll talk about that in a second too because it
definitely felt like they were setting that up
number nine welcome back to trask so they actually
begin the episode with the scene from the trailer
of the razor crest just limping its way to trask
ready to fall apart at the seams even though baby
yoda wasn't that big during the episode they keep
focusing on him in the tank making you think that
he's going to continue to try and poach those
eggs the re-entry gear is all fried so they have
to come in hot they played for a big joke trying
to make him seem really badass as he pulls off the
landing as the mon calamari dock master is yelling
at him to slow down then completely taking it back
when the razor crest winds up in the drink they
haul it out the mon calamari dock worker says
that he can get the ship in shape to fly again
not totally repaired but fix it at least we get
a brief peek at sasha banks character who's named
kaska reeves a lot of people wondering if she was
gonna be sabine wren this is the confirmation that
she is playing a totally new character this is not
somebody from the star wars universe before they
created her for this episode they make another
joke about baby yoda being hungry for eggs then
he takes him to get some soup which they then play
for another joke there were actually a couple
old boy references during the episode with the
slurping of the tentacles they played for a little
bit of comedy with the facehuggers going for baby
yoda also an alien reference too if you want to
think about it that way if you're not familiar
with old boy it's a crazy movie i'd recommend you
check it out at some point but if you wondered
why there were so many people slurping tentacles
in the episode that's what they were referencing
the number eight mando and baby yoda versus the
mamacore the quorn fisherman and his crew say they
can lead the mando to more mandalorians a few
hours away obviously it's just a ploy for them
to steal his best gar steel armor because it's
so valuable they did say that there were other
mandalorians in the area later we do find out
that they were referencing Bo Katan's character
in the night owls but before they show up the
Quarren just punts baby yoda into the maw of
the mama core they're really careful to show you
him closing the shell completely before it gets
swallowed but mando obviously dives in after him
without thinking twice about it but then also in
a bit of a call back to season 1 episode 3 when
he gets saved by the mandalorians just as he's
getting ready to die a group of other mandalorians
show up to rescue him bo katan and her night owls
so if you're not familiar with boca tan or
you didn't watch the clone wars episodes katie
sakhoff is playing boca tan crees she was the last
known leader of all the combined mandalorian clans
before the great purge i'll talk about the
darksaber in a second because she references
it a couple times during the episode that's
obviously a big part of her story that they
set up and they're going to continue on hopefully
in a spin-off series but the other two members of
her squad here are sasha banks character who i
said is named coska reeves not somebody from the
star wars universe before this guy's name is axe
wolves he's also a brand new character as well
you probably recognize him too he's being
played by simon cass from agents of shield
if you're not familiar with the night owls they're
just a separate elite group of female mandalorian
warriors that were led by bokutan before she
joined the death watch mandalorians led by
pree vizsla then when darth maul wound up killing
pre vizsla and taking control of death watch they
kind of split in half half of the night owls chose
to serve darth maul when he had taken control of
mandalore the planet and the other half went with
both Katan but before she died her sister duchess
satine kries obi-wan kenobi's love interest
she was also a member of the night owls as
well even though she was kind of a pacifist they
completely explained the whole helmet rule when
she takes her helmet off immediately and mando
gets all pissed off wait a minute he gives him
the exact same speech that he gave to cobb vance
in episode one you're not a true man to laurie
and she's like hold the phone there buddy i've
been amanda laurie in my entire life i was born
on the planet mandalore the way she explains it
though is that he is a child of the watch i think
that's a reference to death watch because he was
rescued by the death watch mandalorians when she
says that they're basically a cult that splintered
off from mandalorian society and tried to return
to the ancient ways of their people which sounds
a little bit like the death watch mandalorians
i think they just dropped the death from the
watch so i think that's what they're referencing
so in future episodes that will explain why some
mandalorians don't take their helmets off and some
do run around with their helmets off she gives
you a quick explainer on the end of the clone wars
episodes by saying that i'm the last of my line
because her sister duchess the teen crees died
she says she fought in the great purge obviously
they just keep referencing that eventually they'll
explain a little bit more about that history then
i love the look of recognition on her face and
that kind of ryze smile when she looks at baby
yoda like she knows exactly what's going on oh
i've seen one of these before because she knows
all about yoda she knew him during the clone
wars pretty well obviously the child is not yoda
himself he's just a child of yoda's race that's
why we call him baby yoda he is a baby of yoda's
species when he says that what they're doing is
not the way of mandalore this is not the way
he's speaking of mandalore the great that they
keep mentioning especially during season one the
tarre vizsla mandalorian jedi character the number
seven Bo Katan's secret mission so obviously this
is teasing a much much bigger plot way too big
for them to cover just on the mandalorian series
this is where we get into a game of space thrones
territory mando's walking through the docks at
night a group of corn show up to try and kill him
then just like season 1 episode 3 bogatan and
the night owls jet pack in to save him and they
just cut through them like butter and then go to
the bar can we buy you a drink bo katan explains
her grand plan to retake their homeworld mandalore
and seat a new mandalore leader on the throne now
she doesn't tell him the whole story she doesn't
say that i'm going to be the new mandalore and she
doesn't tell him about the darksaber yet but
she does explain basically what they're doing
we're trying to steal a bunch of weapons that have
been passing through here and use them to arm our
divisions of mandalorians so that we can retake
the planet and they give you a whole bunch more
history about what happened to the mandalorians
in their planet during the imperial era of the
original trilogy mando tells stories about how
the empire made the planet even more uninhabitable
than it was to begin with after they realized they
couldn't control it but boca tan claims that's all
just lies that they're telling them so that they
won't reunite under a single banner they want to
keep the mandalorians separated because there's
such a threat to them when he talks about the
planet being inhospitable he's actually talking
about the dome cities most of the surface of the
planet itself was rendered uninhabitable during
the final jedi mandalorian wars almost a thousand
years ago so it's been a long long time but if
you ever wondered why the mandalorians live in
those domed cities when they have an entire
planet that's why she also lets him know she
knows exactly where to find some jedi and they
just confirm exactly what his mission is i think
some people were confused when the armor said take
him to his own kind and she was referring to the
jedi some people thought trying to find other
members of yoda's race mando just confirms that
when we're talking about his kind quote unquote
we're talking about other jedi number six the
big clone wars mission to take the weapons so the
imperial gozanti freighter actually showed up many
many times during clone wars episodes so the ship
may have seemed familiar bogotan being a major
clone wars character probably one of the biggest
most important clone wars characters that they've
introduced on the series so no surprise there were
a lot of clone wars easter eggs during the episode
they make another reference to banthas from
tatooine when they're talking about their attack
again mando has to leave baby yoda with the frogs
they make another joke about him snatching eggs
when he coos up to the tank and mando tells him
to stop it but you do see one of them hatch but
they then pay off at the end of the episode with
it swimming around in the bowl so they have been
fertilized there's a really badass scene of mando
and the night owls on the approach in formation
with their jet packs just really shows you how
good some of their special effects can be and we
get our next celebrity guest star titus welver
who played the man in black on lost he's also
been on a bunch of other series so you probably
recognize him from somewhere they didn't actually
give him a name on the show his character is just
called the captain you also may recognize these
two pilot characters from agents of shield which
is also obviously disney because it's abc star
wars is disney so don't be surprised if a lot of
the guest actors seem very familiar loved all the
scenes of boca tan and mando teaming up to take
down all these stormtroopers they make more jokes
about the stormtroopers being terrible because
the mandalorians are just cutting through them
like it's no big deal there must be ten of them
no wait we're only reading four life signs sir
when the officer on the deck starts yelling
at them to close the doors which one all them
that's a star wars new hope reference when they're
in the garbage compactor yelling at c-3po at r2d2
open the doors open all the doors then they play
it off for a joke where did you trap them inside
the control room which they then used to just vent
them out into the atmosphere there were a lot of
suspenseful jokes like that during the episode
like they play it up big time and then just yank
the rug out from under you the number five what
i would call a boca tan spin-off series teaser
bogatan references arming an entire division of
mandalorians with the weapons talking to titus
welver's character as she reveals that they're
not just taking the weapons but the entire ship
we will need this in the wars to come she talks
about needing to reclaim something that's hers if
she is to rule mandalore obviously she's talking
about the darksaber which she then references by
name later in the episode she and mando have a bit
of a standoff because she keeps changing the deal
on him and they have a bit of an empire strikes
back darth vader lando calrissian reference
pray that i don't alter the deal further this deal
keeps getting worse all the time she also says the
trademark phrase a couple times during the episode
this is the way but the way they sell it in the
episode this much much larger story to completely
reunite the mandalorian people retake the planet
and defeat moff gideon just sounds way too big
to cover it all just on the mandalorian series
which is why i'm talking about boca tan spin-off
series there was a big announcement this week
that disney is going to have a special investor
meeting december 10th where they'll give a bunch
of previews for upcoming disney plus content
a lot of people think that they're going to
use that to also announce some of the other star
wars disney plus spin-off series so i feel like
just doing a spin-off for her is a no-brainer
with the night owls she's probably one of the
biggest characters from the clone wars series
that they could ever do in live action and if you
didn't watch the clone wars series katie sackov
did the voice of bo katan on that so which is a
really cool example of an actress being perfect
for the live-action version of her character i
know because a lot of people wondered why ashley
eckstein wasn't gonna be the live-action version
of ahsoka and it was gonna be rosario dawson
don't worry we'll find out about that in a
future episode but number four welcome back moff
gideon we finally see him again for the first time
titus wellibur's character talks to him they talk
about pirates hitting their ships obviously a
reference to what bogotan has been doing in the
area stealing all the weapons and ships she can
also a bit of a deep cut the mandalorian season
3 is getting ready to start filming really soon
in the working title is actually buccaneer
which is just another kind of pirate so that
could imply that the pirates boca tan and her
other mandalorians so to speak will come back
again during season three in a bigger way
but i love the way moff gideon is a straight
up cold he says backup is no longer an option you
know what to do i think it was pretty clear what
he was implying there but they don't make you
wait too long to figure out what's going on as
he kills both of his men and then prepares
to crash the ship killing himself as well
when they repeat long live the empire that's just
another teaser from off gideon's plans for the
galaxy sort of reforming the empire and retaking
control of the galaxy from the new republic and
the whole reason why he ordered them to destroy
the ship rather than try and save it is because
he didn't want Bo Katan to be able to use those
weapons against him later the number three the
darksaber in boca tan versus moff gideon bokutan
confirms that maf gideon does have the darksaber
and that she is going to find him and take it from
him obviously teasing more conflict later in the
series or in the Bo Katan spin-off series and i
love that he activates his electric suicide pill
not because he's trying to avoid giving her more
information or leading her to moth gideon is that
he's more afraid of what moth gideon would do to
him if he showed up with her in tow they made a
couple of darth vader references during season 1
in the finale when the scout troopers talk about
moff gideon executing stormtroopers because he
was getting impatient with them very darth vader
thing to do killing your underlings when you get
really pissed off at them the number two welcome
to the mandalorian ahsoka tano she finally speaks
ahsoka tano's name and it's the first time in a
live-action star wars series or story of any
kind that ahsoka's name has ever been uttered
she also offers him a spot on the night owls if
you want to join us on our mission you're welcome
to but obviously i think they're just teasing that
that's going to happen on another series because i
have my story my story is to be with baby yoda and
help him find his people she tells him to take the
child baby yoda to the city of calidan on the
fourth planet of corvus corvus actually is an
easter egg for the star wars battlefront ship
that aiden versio uses with her inferno group
speaking of which that's another character that
could actually show up in live action an actress
who voices a character an animation who could just
as easily do them in live action because of when
this happens in the timeline but hopefully we'll
see boca tan again at least by the season finale
they have to follow up with the dark saber of the
mov gideon stuff before she goes off into season
3 or whatever her spin-off series is gonna wind
up being hopefully she gets a spin-off series the
number one mando heads off to take baby yoda to
ahsoka all the netting all over the razor crest
just makes it seem even more like a fishing vessel
then they play up another facehucker joke with an
even bigger one almost eating baby yoda but then
mando catching it in baby yoda doing another old
boy reference slurping it down and i don't know if
we're gonna wind up seeing ahsoka in next week's
episode or if she'll be episode 5 but i think dave
filoni directed and wrote episode 5 so i assumed
that that would be the ahsoka episode because
he created that character with george lucas and
she's so precious to him so why wouldn't he direct
the episode that she appears in for the first time
so even though he's headed there in episode 4
don't be surprised if they have something that
makes him get sidetracked the same way that
episode 2 was sort of an in-between episode
before we got to the really cool episode 3. but
if you spotted any other big star wars references
during the episode that i didn't mention in
the video just write them below in the comments
just amazing episode even though it was very
short there'll be a couple big bonus videos that
i'll do for bogatan the other mandalorians and
the stories that they set up during the episode
so if you have any other requests for star wars
videos just leave them in the comments as well
my full season 2 episode 4 video will post next
friday just like normal and i'll name a giveaway
winner when i post my next star wars bonus
video everyone click here to learn what's going
on with luke skywalker during the mandalorian
season 2 and click here for all my mandalorian
season 2 episode videos thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!